foreign
welcome to the minimalist podcast where
we discuss what it means to live a
meaningful life with less my name is
Joshua Fields Milburn and I'm Ryan
Nicodemus and together we're the
minimalists we're here with malabama hi
everybody TK Coleman all as well we've
got the rest of our team here in the
studio as well and coming up today on
this free public minimal episode we're
joined by Dr Zach Bush a triple board
certified physician and internationally
recognized educator and expert on the
microbiome as it relates to health
disease and Food Systems together we're
talking to a few listeners about
decluttering the gut then at the end of
this episode we are going to skip our
lightning round segment because Dr bush
has some shocking news to share with us
you can check out the full three hour
maximal edition of this episode where we
answer five times the questions and we
dive deep into some of the most eyebrow
raising conversations we've ever had on
this show that private podcast episode
is out right now at patreon.com the
minimalists your support keeps our
podcast and YouTube Channel 100
advertisement free because say it with
me y'all
by the way if you're on the fence
patreon is now offering free trials so
you can check out that full three hour
episode for free you can test drive the
minimalist private podcast you can join
for seven days try it out just visit
patreon or patreon Pages click the link
in the description uh to this episode to
subscribe and you'll get your personal
link so that our weekly maximal episodes
play in your favorite podcast app you'll
also gain access to all of our archives
all the way back to episode zero zero
one that's a whole lot more of less
let's start with our callers if you have
a question or comment for our show give
us a call
406-219-7839 or email voice recording to
podcast at the minimalists.com our first
question today is from Sherry my name is
Sherry Torres and I'm a new patreon
subscriber I am 61 years young I'm
post-menopausal post hysterectomy 100
cancer free I want to have great gut
health actually I need to have great gut
health a few years back I suffered for
about a year with lymphocytic colitis as
a result of regular ibuprofen use I am
now off all NSAIDs of any kind don't
touch them anymore but every time I go
shopping for probiotics I'm completely
overwhelmed with all the different types
all the different dosages all the
different maladies that each one
promises to come back my question is is
there a non-confusing
non-overwhelming guide to adding
probiotics to my diet
one of our listeners Nastasia wrote in
she said that
um we should do an episode about
decluttering the gut and I found that
fascinating and since Zach is here and
he is an expert on gut health I thought
this was a great question to start with
so Dr Bush when we're talking about
probiotics that's a sliver of the
picture we're talking about gut health
there's so much that goes into it when
in doubt I tend to avoid the synthetic
route whether that is
um ibuprofen as she mentioned I mean any
of these sort of prescription or
over-the-counter drugs that are abused
often damage the gut but there's so many
other things that damage our gut can we
talk about some of those things
yeah to to reflect on the question there
you know we've got somebody who's gone
through some Health crisis and you've
got multiple surgeries and you have
history of probably intensive drug
treatment on top of that radiation
therapy all this that we put people
through when they have something like
cancer and so uh Western medicine which
is my background 17 years in Academia
there and academic medicine practicing
not only the clinical side but also
basic scientists working on chemotherapy
development at the University of
Virginia over the years and I was
trained in this belief that
the system of the body was actually
really predictable like you know here's
here's the receptor we can hit that with
a drug and this will happen so we had
this very Newtonian training that here
it is this is the machine you push this
lever and this happens it's a very
predictable and so they want you to
believe that because that's the only way
that we could actually intervene as a
reductionist approach of a
pharmaceutical industry to actually you
know create change and they they did
this in such a way that yeah you never
see the forest for the trees right and
so you're so focused on your one tree
that you can't realize that you're part
of a larger system whether you're a drug
developer or a clinician you're always
just seeing this small segment and you
can't see the force for the trees which
will be a theme that will play off into
today's episode I think is we'd never
quite get to see the full picture and
therefore we keep making these
reductionist decisions about the world
and therefore we can go down these deep
rabbit holes of belief not realizing
that we left the rails four decades past
and so now in a pharmaceutical World
we're trained here's a receptor that
causes high blood pressure and here's a
drug that interrupts that pathway and so
this is going to lower your blood
pressure
but what is missed there is that there's
this huge Cascade of events that are
occurring around that receptor and we
forget that this is a symphony of 70
trillion cells that are dancing with 1.4
quadrillion bacteria that are dancing
with 14 quadrillion mitochondria all of
which are different species that are
interplaying through genetics through
hormonal Cascades through something
called redox chemistry or this kind of
cellular system of of wireless
communication so you have this Exquisite
Network and then you take something like
a non-steroidal anti-inflammatory which
is a sledgehammer on just a very narrow
spectrum of biology and the whole thing
gets out of balance and so the
experience of I've taken these NSAIDs
for a while and then my body went
haywire is predictable NSAIDs just for
for clarification can you can you talk
more about the non-straal
anti-inflammatories the common ones are
ibuprofen you know the brands are things
like Motrin and the like
and they're in contrast to Tylenol which
is acetaminophen which is a pathway that
disrupts liver metabolism this is a
something that disrupts the Cascade of
inflammation within the cell and what we
find is these things do disrupt the
ecosystem of the body and there's a lot
of common over-the-counter drugs that do
this I would say that Ibuprofen is most
commonly abused that is directly
damaging but aspirin is right up there
with high damage to the gut lining
there's a lot of people that believe
that aspirin trying to get onto the
market today would have never made it by
FDA regulations because it causes so
much gut bleeding so much mortality from
aspirin but here we've had it for 100
years I kind of got grandfathered into
the process but is it dangerous you know
compound that really screws up a whole
you know slew of of issues in the gut
and Beyond so we take these medications
another one that's very common now that
you can actually buy by the near gallon
at Costco is is Miralax for constipation
and so ironically that's common
complication of chronic abuse of
anti-inflammatories and legs so you're
taking anti-inflammatories then your
bowels start to get off the neurology
gets screwed up you start to get
constipation patterns so now you're
taking Miralax and both of those drugs
do disrupt the really Foundation of gut
health which is the tight junctions
which are the velcro like proteins that
keep your gut as a coherent barrier to
the outside world
and so what we start to realize is that
the pharmaceutical industry in its
effort to intervene on complex systems
starts to disrupt the regenerative
quality of the body the body should be
repairing constantly and your expression
of disease is going to be equal to your
rate of injury versus your rate of
repair as your rate of repair starts to
go down your rate of injury starts to
accumulate damage and that damage
accumulates into what we call chronic
diseases right and so these
anti-inflammatories and many other drugs
on the market Miralax and the like
unintentionally start to fuel the
chronic disease epidemic because it's
slowing the repair process down and so
that would be things like your ibuprofen
your aspirin they're slowing down repair
process anything that disrupts the
normal acute inflammatory reaction which
is your reaction to injury if you start
to dull that you're not you're not
addressing the injury and so you're
starting to accumulate disease
but like you said it goes far beyond the
Pharmaceuticals on the other side of the
pharmaceutical industry is the chemical
agriculture side and so the herbicides
and pesticides that saturate our food
system today are antibiotics and
anti-inflammatories and so they actually
are functioning to destroy the same
Pathways but now at you know a ecosystem
level much greater than what might
happen if you just ingested an ibuprofen
you're now ingesting in your water your
food system you're actually breathing it
it's raining on you about 85 percent of
the rain measured in the U.S is positive
for glyphosate the most common weed
killer you herbicide on the market and
that's a very potent antibiotic and so
as we start to be steeped in these
chemicals the air we breathe 85 of the
air we breathe contaminated so Every
Breath You Take now is starting to
diminish your ecosystem repair and your
ecosystem communication and for that we
end up with this diminished capacity for
regeneration and we're repair and
unfortunately that's not just happening
in the human God it's also happening in
the gut of the world which is the soil
and so our soil systems which is the gut
of the planet and we're responsible for
the whole metabolism and repair process
of the planet is decrementing at the
same rate that our gut is and so for
this we see the collapse of ecosystems
so all this talk about CO2 in the
atmosphere all that that's that's
chasing literally after the wind that's
that's very tiny fraction 0.04 percent
of our atmosphere is CO2 that's not
causing Extinction what's causing
Extinction is the destruction of the gut
of the planet and humans on it and so we
are losing the ecosystem communication
the ecosystem regenerative capacity of
the planet and this woman is
experiencing that and her questions
around probiotics and she said go to the
market and we have 47 billion dollar
industry now built around probiotics
globally and it turns out the pro box
are three or seven species that you take
in very high dose you're taking billions
and billions they'll brag about it too
on the label 50 billion copies 100
billion copies of this bacteria this
bacteria every time I see that I'm like
I don't even know what that means like
50 billion what anyway that's it and you
can't wrap your mind around that number
either like nobody actually can picture
a billion bacteria wow it's a lot I
think I'll go for the more right yeah
that's the other disease we have is more
and more and more right so more
probiotics that's probably going to help
me out as well yeah yeah so what's the
minimalist approach to gut health
is really starting to back up and say
what does the force look like what is an
ecosystem of the gut look like and the
answer is pretty amazing the American
gut project which is Miss term because
most work's been done over in Africa but
they've been looking at what is the
ideal gut Flora look like of a human and
so they're studying under gather tribes
over in Kenya and other places to
realize that an ideal gut that's really
in touch with its ecosystem in touch
with its food directly it's hunting it's
touching the height of the animals it
eats it's touching the honeycomb that it
consumes it's touching the nature from
which its Foods come 40 000 species of
bacteria is pretty typical measurement
and our genomics aren't even very good
yet like we're probably off by 10x at
least so somewhere in that 40 000 to 400
000 is probably the right number of
species of bacteria alone and that's
logarithmically outnumbered by the
number of fungi yeast protozoa all these
other organisms in the gut the American
got in contrast has 10 000 species at
best typically more like five to eight
thousand species so we've lost 75 as
Western consumers Western eaters we've
lost 75 of the workforce or 75 percent
of the ecosystem and there are a few
reasons for that just to to clarify here
one is what you mentioned the the
overuse of over-the-counter prescription
drugs for example I had a doctor who
gave me an antibiotic for 13 years that
I took daily totally decimated my gut
you couple that with the glyphosates and
other pesticides that are in
conventional foods like a regular tomato
you get from Ralph's if it is
conventional it's been sprayed by
glyphosate or some other pesticide and
one dose of that probably not a big deal
to the average human being when we
continue to assault ourselves over and
over and over and then of course the
foods we're eating the heavily processed
foods don't they also don't help with
the the overall gut health of the human
being that's right and so what we've
done is say well here's the probiotic
here's three species that will fix your
gut and so we give you billions of
copies of three or now there's like
seven species probiotics on the market
and there's even like Garden of Life I
think has a 25 species one but 25
species of billions of copies when
you're supposed to have 40 000 species
is the exact same thing that we've done
with farming is hmm here's a monocrop of
corn soybean and wheat you go plant
those three species over 125 million
Acres what could possibly go wrong
the answer is well the ecosystem starts
to fundamentally collapse because you
eliminate all the biodiversity of of the
floor on the planet in the same way we
go in with a monocrop of probiotics and
say well here's three species and then
it's and you can see that all the
marketing companies even though they're
really fancy new you know probiotics on
the market are launched by marketing
teams not by scientists right and it's
like okay we have an idea it's going to
look more beautiful and we're going to
go after this thing and and so these
marketing teams come up with a new look
the new feel the new you know messaging
about because Guy health is a massive
you know near trillion dollar industry
coming on here and so everybody's got a
lot of space to compete
but the scientists started to get
concerned you know decades back of like
wow I wonder if this is even good for
somebody you know in the 1970s they
starting pound people with billions of
copies of three species and so the study
started to get done and finally the
definitive ones got published in 2018 to
show that we were actually diminishing
the microbiome diversity and recovery
after antibiotics using probiotics and
so the probiotic after two weeks of
antibiotics two weeks of antibiotics to
start with well decimate your ecosystem
and buy another 80 so you've already
missing 75 of your ideal guide you take
an antibiotic for two weeks and you've
lost another eighty percent so you're
down to a couple thousand species of
bacterium
and your gut's now going to struggle
back to get back to its Baseline of ten
thousand species
and the studies that needed to be done
that finally got done were Placebo
controlled and so they took sugar pills
basically and they showed complete gut
recovery back to a baseline within 30
days
versus probiotic that followed out six
months still had never recovered wow and
so they showed the same level of
suppression of the microbiome with a
probiotic as the antibiotic had caused
now let me ask you does that also apply
to Natural probiotics so like for
example I will drink kefir daily like a
raw coconut kefir or a raw dairy kefir I
assume that's a little bit different
than the pill antibiotic probably not
unfortunately so most of your most of
your yogurts and kefirs are single
species ferments and so they'll add
acidophilus or one of these you know
classic fermentation things to get away
from that you have to have what would be
called a wildly fermented product and
wild fermentation is a process where you
expose the sugar water basically to Air
and the air is delivering thousands of
species of yeast bacteria all kinds of
Flora and then you start to get in so
this is the classic sauerkraut that was
made in a croc in your grandmother's
basement right maybe your great
grandmother's basement but Crocs were
like handed down generation to
generation because it was one of the
most important ways to preserve food and
we did that right up until the 1950s
when Refrigeration got so cheap and
Universal that we just got lazy and we
started doing vinegar pickles and things
that could be stuck in the fridge and
not necessarily kept at room temperature
for for years and so that loss of
fermentation in the wild setting led to
a decrement of true gut health for us in
the 1950s 60s and then we started adding
herbicides pesticides over those decades
and we started destroying ecosystems so
it was a loss of a food culture and and
the innovation of antibiotics as a crop
treatment that really started to destroy
the ecosystem of health and so that's
where we see the sudden acceleration of
collapse of ecosystems and global
warming and all these stories starting
to come out in 1980s 90s and you start
to see the the emergence of the chronic
disease epidemics of the 1990s that now
explodes and that so that's autism in
our children it's asthma and our
children it's X-Men our children it's
attention deficit disorder all that
stuff was UN Untold before 1992. 1992 we
we started spraying wheat with
glyphosate directly to dry it out right
before harvesting and we suddenly get
gluten sensitivity and so we don't
actually have Gluten Sensitive we have
glyphosate sensitivity
and so we've been poisoned by our own
agricultural system and this is leading
to this destruction of guy health and
then we answer it with probiotics no
problem here's your three species and so
what we've done as a laboratory for the
last 10 years is we've been utilizing
not bacteria but the communication
network of bacteria as an answer to guy
health and so we extract these small
carbon molecules made by bacteria and
fungi and soil systems and deliver that
back to the human body so they can get
that cell cell communication back in
touch
and when you get communication you get
recovery you accelerate repair across
all systems and so we've been studying
the influence of this cellular
communication of bacteria on human cell
systems for the last 15 years and it
just explodes the the rate of repair and
like I said rate of injury versus rate
of repair is how young are you how much
disease do you carry and so to see
people accelerate their youth accelerate
their repair process has been really
exciting and humbling because it's not a
human system it's a microbial system
that accelerates human repair right and
so in the end what we're really saying
is the belief that there's such a thing
as human health is inaccurate there's
planetary Health there's ecosystem
health and we are an expression of that
ecosystem human life and human health is
an expression of an ecosystem
of millions of species fungi yeast
bacteria all the rest and so we are an
expression of Nature and until we come
to terms with that we're going to
continue to battle nature we're going to
war against that nature yes can we get
practical for a second for Sherry to
wrap up her question because she's at a
point now where she's probably suffering
to some extent and that suffering is not
because of her gut health necessarily
but it is exacerbated significantly by a
damaged gut and so someone like that as
opposed to saying hey here are your
probiotics have a nice day what do we
tell her from a practical standpoint
yeah so getting back in touch with your
ecosystem is the answer and so looking
at the fermented foods being a good
example for pennies you can it's water
and and salt and so you create water
salt combination it's called a Brine and
then you put your cabbage in there for
two dollars and within two weeks you
have a huge huge vat of sauerkraut that
would have cost you 25 bucks at the
grocery store and so for pennies you can
start to do gut recovery by being in
communication with the air around you
and allowing that air to begin to do it
keeping in mind that the air that you're
breathing may be contaminated with
herbicides and everything so it's really
like how do we start to get the
intelligence back into our air system
the answer is get back in touch with
nature and so an interesting concept
would be take that Croc with that towel
over it and go and take a hike in the
woods and set that under a tree in in
the woods for a few hours and see what
that Forest wants to deliver to your gut
through that and so getting back in
touch with nature through a literal
reconnect or literal reintroduction of
what Nature has and its diversity is a
key feature and so the hashtag breathe
your biome has been one of the big
things that I launched 10 years ago and
the concept is if you are out in nature
in different ecosystems every minute
you're out there you're introducing New
Life to your body and for that you're
diversifying the body so fermented foods
getting out in nature hiking in it
swimming in it diving in it whatever
you're doing get out in nature and touch
it and then if you want a deep dive on
the science of that soil microbial
communication Network
intelligenceofnature.com can get you
that big body of science that we've
developed over the last 15 years and you
can start to drink some of that you know
in small amounts it's just a few few
milliliters you know a teaspoon a day
can start to move you in that direction
of reconnection to the communication
network of life and so that accelerates
the tight Junction repair and builds
that barrier between the outside world
and your immune system to reignite that
healthy relationship between you and the
world around you the world within you we
now know that there's an ecosystem
within you as well not just in your gut
but the brain has bacteria fungi yeast
in it that are a healthy ecosystem and
so these systems that we thought were
sterile and had to be sterile to be
healthy we're now realizing are these
diverse ecosystems and and as we call
the ecosystem we lose health and so as
you reintegrate into the nature from
which you have emerged you're going to
ReDiscover yourself and so for you you
know here coming out of chronic disease
the chronic disease was there as an
invitation back into nature and so for
all the fearful statistics and all that
nature is just wrapping us up in her
arms saying come on back I got you I got
you yeah Sherry we'll put a link to any
of the resources that we mentioned today
throughout the podcast in the show notes
over at the minimalists.com so you'll
have access to them over there and now a
word from our sponsor
oh that would be absolutely awful
thankfully advertisements suck we don't
do any ads you all know that big shout
out to our patreon subscribers I wanted
to interrupt this podcast episode with
Dr Zach Bush we're talking about
decluttering the gut and I wanted this
to be the definitive place where people
can go to optimize their gut to heal
their gut long time listeners of the
podcast will know that I've gone through
some terrible gut health over the last
four and a half years and I've been able
to nurse myself back to health to heal
my gut to a great extent and in fact
heal my life in general because gut
health is Health if you don't have gut
health you will suffer that's the
biggest thing I've learned over the last
five years so I wanted to step in here
for just a moment interrupt the podcast
with Dr Zach Bush and talk about some
things I didn't want to interrupt the
flow with him and so talk about some
things I know he would be on board with
but these are things that help me
specifically they may or may not help
you if you're listening to this episode
but these are the things that help me
heal my gut the first thing I did was I
eliminated anything that damages my gut
microbiome anything that damages the
mucosal wall of the intestinal tract so
that's a one cell thick layer we call it
leaky gut when it gets disrupted right
and there are a lot of foods drugs
alcohol any of that stuff can disrupt
your mucosal layer could cause it to be
permeable and that creates that leaky
gut that allows a bunch of things toxins
to leak into your system that you don't
want the two big foods for me were seed
oils and processed foods getting those
out of my diet listen to episode 384 of
the minimalist podcast because we did a
whole episode about food clutter and
what foods to subtract for you from your
life in order to have Optimal Health
including optimal gut health the second
thing I did was removing fiber from my
diet for a period of time eating low
fiber or no fiber foods was hyper
important to me it's not that I think
fiber is inherently bad but if you have
a injured gut just like TK if you had an
injured arm right now and it had a big
ulcer on it and I went over and started
rubbing on it really hard you play Hey
man get off that really really hurts and
fiber can do the same thing to a damaged
gut now if I went over to your smooth
clean muscular arm now in sort of
rubbing like oh that feels kind of nice
yeah right yeah but if you have a
damaged gut you want to stop the damage
you want to keep damaging high fiber
foods were really damaging my gut I had
to remove all fiber from my diet for a
period of time for me it ended up being
a couple years wow I don't necessarily
I'm not recommending that to anyone but
understanding it doesn't happen
overnight the gut healing takes some
time and we don't want to re-offend
re-injure the gut and when it came to
repopulating the gut with the good
bacteria that we want you often hear
about probiotics but as Dr Bush talks
about on this podcast episode a
probiotic can only go so far
I prefer to have fermented foods there's
a great book called The Art of
fermentation I'll put a link to that in
the show notes every day I'm eating
really high quality fermented carrots
and beets and cabbage and kimchi I'm
also drinking water kefir or coconut
water kefir that was really important
for me and my gut health repopulated my
gut because I took antibiotics for 13
years don't recommend that but it
decimated my gut it made my gut feel
awful and it got rid of all the good
guys in my gut which made room for a lot
of the bad guys to come in and wreak
havoc and I had terrible bowel movements
my bowel movements are great now I had
awful indigestion IBS IBD
ulcers in my small bowel I had
significant problems in the gut so I had
to repopulate the gut with good bacteria
why were you taking
this for over a decade a doctor said
that I had this scalp acne these nodular
cysts on my head I didn't know at the
time was a soy allergy and he said oh
here's a quick fix and of course being a
standard American I that's what I really
wanted was the Quick Fix we didn't talk
about diet we didn't talk about anything
that might affect my skin but your skin
is a manifestation of gut dysfunction so
whenever I have a gut dysfunction it
will manifest in several ways one is
blemishes on the skin or even autoimmune
conditions eczema psoriasis things like
that and a pill will help with the
symptoms but it's not going to cure the
problem what will is getting a healthy
gut microbiome together and so what I've
done is I reintroduce fermented foods
that we make at home you can buy some
affirmative Foods at the store but it's
much better to make your own fermented
foods high quality you get all the
strains of bacteria they're going to
help out however I will say this
start small and start slow you want to
be really careful I remember once I took
a just a regular probiotic that a doctor
recommended this was a few years ago and
I ended up in the hospital because my
gut wasn't ready for that much gut new
bacteria being introduced into my gut
and so when I say start small I mean
literally small I take some coconut raw
coconut water kefir that you can either
make at home or you can buy a really
high quality Organic Raw one from a
store and literally would dip my finger
into it and just barely get it into my
mouth because I found if I took a big
Swig of it it wreaked havoc on my gut
you work your way up you start small and
the same is true with any fermented
foods as well a lot of bacteria there
and if your gut's not ready for it uh oh
that's also going to cause a problem but
if you slowly introduce those things
what you're doing is you're improving
your gut health now the average person
if they don't have dysbiosis in their
gut fermented foods are still great idea
because 80 percent of your immune system
is in your gut what you're doing is
you're fortifying your gut and thus
fortifying your immune system our immune
system is our health a few other things
I've done really quick colostrum has
helped in the past it has a lot of
essential nutrients it's the first
milking of a cow or a ruminant animal
and that is helpful because those
nutrients are what really helps a baby
become healthy it gives them what they
need and so uh again you may be
sensitive to something like Dairy and so
be really careful with something like
that there's also there are supplement
companies like heart and soil no
affiliation to me but that cell
colostrum so that you can you can take a
just a quick capsule of colostrum but
always start small if you have a
sensitivity that's probably something I
would avoid altogether stick with the
fermented foods and then also
understanding what is going wrong with
your gut I've done a thousand well
probably literally dozens of different
tests for my gut testing my microbiome
through my poop the only one that I
found to be especially helpful was from
a company called para Wellness
parawellnessresearch.com we'll put a
link to that in the show notes you
basically get your poop tested and they
tell you what's going on there what
parasites What bacterias are invasive do
you have an overgrowth of growth of
yeast that was a big problem for me
because when we got rid of all that
bacteria my gut through the antibiotics
we made room for all the yeast to just
overgrow and so I had something called
sifo small intestinal fungal overgrowth
I had an abundance of fungus in my gut
and para Wellness gives you ways to deal
with that naturally so you don't
necessarily need a prescription to deal
with any of these gut parasites yeast or
bacteria a few other things that have
nothing to do directly with the gut but
help my gut health and my inflammation
significantly grounding you can go back
and listen to our episode with Clint
Ober about grounding
phenomenal episode I ground every day
now grounding is absolutely free to get
your bare feet on the ground I also use
some grounding products from
earthing.com also not a sponsor I'm
sitting on a grounding mat right now TK
is standing on a grounding mat as well I
sleep on a grounding mat at night
staying grounded really helps me they
also have a great documentary it's about
15 minutes long you can learn the
science behind grounding and why it is
so important for your life to reduce
inflammation because a lot of the gut
this ease that we have is gut
inflammation systemic inflammation and
grounding helps ease and eliminate the
inflammation throughout our entire body
a few other things I've done that help
my immune system cold exposure and hot
exposure so cold through ice baths or
cold showers really helps I used to just
throw a bunch of ice into a bathtub I'm
lucky enough to have an ice bath in my
backyard now I've been doing this for
years at this point but now I do it
every single day because I have access
to it if you don't have access to a cold
plunge you can simply do a cold shower
for two minutes a day that cold exposure
it increases or it helps out your immune
system and so if you're helping your
immune system you're also helping your
gut because 80 of your immune system is
in your gut heat exposure as well Asana
two or three times a week you could also
do a hot tub or something like that but
or a hot shower but finding a local
sauna your local YMCA or a local
Athletic Club or finding a friend that
has a sauna doing that two or three
times a week by the way quick question
related to the cold shower let's say I
get in and for for three two minutes I
do the cold thing and I'm like ah but
then at the end of that two minutes I'm
like all right I'm going back to comfort
land no have I deprived myself of the
benefit yeah all the benefits you always
want to end with cold and that's really
important so like this morning I got
into the ice bath I spent three minutes
in the ice bath and I shiver myself to
warmth that's where most of the benefits
come and I do it daily at least two
minutes here's the trick though I think
an ice bath is actually easier than an
ice shower cold shower even though it's
much colder the full submersion is so
much better than having that water just
spraying at me chaotically although well
the best thing is whatever you're going
to do so cold exposure helps your immune
system heat exposure helps your immune
system now keep in mind none of this is
medical advice so please consult your
doctor your dentist your Shaman your
Pilates instructor and your local rodeo
clown before taking your life into your
own hands I need to hear the disclaimer
and Bama's voice please
oh one more thing it's my birthday this
week y'all and I only asked this once a
year every podcast we're not hopping on
here and say hey please rate and review
our podcast because I don't want to
clutter your podcast with public service
announcements but it's my birthday will
you be willing to get me a birthday gift
that I will actually enjoy I don't need
more cufflinks I don't need a tie I
don't need a birthday cake all I need is
a review on Apple podcast s or Spotify
if you hop on there and just say hey I
really enjoy this podcast give us five
stars or give us a review that would be
really helpful I asked for this one time
a year on my birthday so we don't
clutter every podcast episode that you
listen to would you be willing to get me
a birthday gift right now it's my 42nd
birthday and the best gift you can get
me is leave us a review Apple podcast or
Spotify you know we have over 16 000
reviews on Apple and we read every one
of them Spotify just started doing
reviews recently so if you listen on
Spotify please give us a review that
helps us reach more ears with our
message of less and if you watch this on
YouTube you can subscribe to this
channel you know almost 70 percent of
the people who watch our videos on
YouTube do not subscribe to our Channel
now is a great chance to do it you're
not going to see me hop into every video
and say please like And subscribe this
is the one time of year if you want to
subscribe we'd really appreciate it we
appreciate y'all that's right and the
the fact that we don't accept ads on our
YouTube videos actually hurts us because
we are not a priority because we're not
profitable to YouTube and the way that
other people who run ads are and so what
that means it's harder for us to be seen
that's one of the prices that we pay for
the stance that we take and so each time
you leave a comment or you subscribe and
you hit like you increase our visibility
on YouTube so that if you support what
we do and you want more people to hear
these ideas you give them a chance to
see it in their timeline news feed or
whatever it is they call it and they
recommended videos and everything I
talked about today with respect to
Healing your gut we'll put links to
those in the show notes over at the
minimalists.com podcast all right let's
get back to the show I want to tune into
one more question here that I think ties
into that perfectly this one is from
gene on Facebook
I already eat mostly organic Whole Foods
but are there any foods I should avoid
or even prioritize to help keep my
hormones balanced so we did an episode
recently with Dr Paul saladino about
food clutter and he talked about some
things to remove from the diet that are
Foods we've introduced that have
basically gotten us away from nature so
seed oils is a big one processed
carbohydrates anything that's
essentially in a package has been
sitting on a shelf for a long period of
time it's a food product but it's not
really the food that you're talking
about artificial sweeteners anything
with pesticides glyphosates Etc
um alcohol as well these things that are
not necessarily in our nature I don't
know that that's not really a
comprehensive list but I think it's
probably a good place to start it's
often about subtraction more than it is
about addition we were always looking
what foods can I what can I put into my
body to make it better but quite often
subtraction is greater than addition
and I I think you just answered that
classic question in the nutrition world
is you know what should we eat should we
be vegan should we be paleo should we be
Keto uh because I know people that went
keto and they only eat meat and they
feel better and then I know people who
went vegan and they feel better well the
answers both those communities stopped
eating the packaged food and so it's not
about what you're eating is about what
you've eliminated and so this is why you
can hear such vehement bickering and
fighting between those camps because
they actually felt better and so they
have convinced by their deductive
reasoning that well it must be the meat
that's making me feel better it must be
the veggies that are making me feel no
it's the lack of canola oil your
bloodstream like it's it's literally the
elimination of these these highly
processed things that are making you
feel better and so the reality is whole
food is the only diet that counts and so
if you're going after Whole Foods you're
going to win the game and biodiversity
again wins the game in that story and so
I do get concerned when people are
saying you know I eat chicken for six
months and I feel much better I'm like
yeah that is one amino acid you are
loading your body with a single amino
acid for months and all you have to do
is go hang out with a carnivore to
realize that's a ridiculous way to eat
because if you go hang out with a lion
and you watch them take down the
wildebeest they never go and eat the
muscle they're not eating the steak
initially they instead rip open the
belly and they eat 40 pounds of organic
composted greens out of the gut of that
thing before they ever touch the meat
yeah because they know they're going to
be constipated to beat the band if they
just go after the muscle and they go eat
a bunch of steak they're not gonna be
able to move their bowels
and so the reason why Costco is now
selling near gallon sizes of Miralax is
because we have this protein addiction
and this protein you know treatment for
diet right now that's just all meat yeah
and when you just put meat in the gut it
takes about 14 hours from it moved from
your stomach to your colon 14 hours
versus you know that high fiber diet
that the lion is eating on the front end
of it or the vegan eating there vegan
meal with the same calories it passes in
90 minutes so it's either an hour and a
half or 14 hours you choose your Transit
time but you're going to have to keep
that thing moving because by the time
you're eating lunch tomorrow you still
have two more meals backed up in your
gut you know that are still trying to
process through and so it's this journey
into this slow bowel thing that then
leads to you know these pharmaceutical
Solutions and taking heavy dose
magnesium and Miralax and everything
else to keep your bowels moving and so
I've never seen a lion take a bunch of
magnesium I was just gonna say Miralax
Miralax now for Lions
this is the a time where we'd usually
enter into our lightning round where we
answer your questions from Tick Tock by
the way you can follow the minimalists
on Instagram Tick Tock Facebook and
Twitter at the minimalist we'll put
links to Dr Zach Bush's social media
handles as well but we're going to
forego the lightning round today I do
have one piece of news for you our first
film minimalism a documentary about the
important things after 80 million views
and seven years on Netflix if you missed
it last week it just came out on YouTube
so you can find that now youtube.com the
minimalist or over at minimalism.com you
can watch the full documentary for free
and 100 advertisement free as you know
with our podcast our patreon subscribers
keep our podcast and our YouTube Channel
100 advertisement free because
advertisements suck yeah let's move on
to right here right now I'm gonna hand
the floor over to Ryan and Dr
usually we use this segment to talk
about one thing that's going on in the
life of the minimalist and one thing
that happened is Ryan and his wife
Mariah and Dr Bush they went out to
lunch last week and Ryan calls me
afterward and he said hey Dr Bush wants
to come on the podcast and he has he has
something to talk about he told me what
it was and I if it wasn't Ryan Nicodemus
and Dr Zach Bush I would have hung up
the phone turned it off changed my phone
number and moved to a new city
so Ryan do you want to set this up and
then we'll uh you can set the pins up
and Dr Bush can bowl him over yeah no
you know it's uh it's interesting
because I've never had to set up a
conversation like this before but yeah
when we were having lunch you
um just kind of delivered something to
me that that really blew my mind and you
know Dr Bush because I respect you so
much man it's like I could not take you
seriously so
um I guess like with that being said
with that being said
um maybe you could Tee It Up for our
audience and why
why you're why you're really here today
yeah so I I can't remember honestly if
we got into in the Lost podcast but a
lot of my last 15 years has dealt with
the microbiome looking at how bacteria
and fungi interact with the human immune
system and then deeper than that the
human neurology and one of the big big
aha moments this last 15 years is the
concept of intelligence and the concept
of intelligence as human is starting to
disappear because we're starting to
realize all the data that is inputted
into your brain to create patterns of
information that would then be able to
exhibit intelligence are being inputted
by bacteria and fungi and so this has
been a lot of my work is to realize that
human consciousness only occurs because
we are the most biodiverse ecosystem
interacting with a single neurology
to put that in a tighter box the human
colon in its Anatomy its exact
anatomical structures has perfected the
ability to hold more ecosystem variety
than any other colon in the history of
the planet wow
meaning we can touch more species of
bacteria fungi yeast protozoa than any
other species has ever touched with our
neurology and we now know that the
nerves that innervate the gut lining
many of them are piercing the gut lining
and sticking this now to these neurons
straight into the milieu of the bacteria
fungi and the rest
and for that we're starting to realize
the fingers on the keyboard of your
computer are non-human they are
literally coming from the ecosystem
itself inputting information into you
that would then become intelligence and
it looks like species and their
intelligence are directly linked to how
much of nature can speak through you
and so this concept of human
intelligence is starting to evaporate
into the microbiome and nature itself
being the source of intelligence and so
the conversation we got into last week
was kind of the macro version of that is
that we've spent a lot of time in
science fiction and in conspiracy theory
and everything else talking about
extraterrestrial intelligence which the
words mean extra Beyond terrestrial
meaning Earth intelligence
extraterrestrial intelligence is it
possible there's an intelligence out
there in the universe and the James Webb
Telescope has blown our minds right we
thought Hubble had shown us the universe
and we thought we had maybe two maybe 20
billion Universe galaxies in the
universe and then James Webb is
uncovered with a much higher resolution
image of the universe and we realized we
were logarithmically off on that that's
more like 2.5 trillion galaxies in the
universe and when you start to wrap your
head around 2.5 trillion galaxies Each
of which has 10 billion Suns so you
can't it's you can't yeah I mean the
Milky Way has a quarter of a trillion
planets like just the one Galaxy let
alone the however many trillions of
galaxies there are multiply that by a
quarter of a trillion yeah it's it's you
can't grasp it although it's very
interesting the micro to macro and so
some of the best papers that I think
have been written in physics this last
decade have shown us that we sit
mathematically in the center of the
universe right between the biggest thing
in the universe to the smallest thing in
the universe we sit in the mathematical
center it's called the universal scaling
law and so you take the frequency of
resonance or the vibration of the
universe itself largest radius that
we've ever measured is the universe the
the foreign
and it's cool that the Universe has a
sound to it yeah far far below our
detection capacity within our neurology
but it's humming and at the highest
pitch noise ever created in the universe
is Planck's cost in which the vibration
of the electromagnetic field in a vacuum
you draw a straight line between the
those two and you can start to plot
everything in nature from galaxies to
quasars to Suns to solar systems planets
to moons to a plant to a feather to an
atom to you keep going down smaller and
smaller ultimately you find that that
perfect line represents everything the
frequency of resonance plotted against
its radius or diameter and dead center
is freaking human biology and so this
thing that we call life seems to be the
center point of the purpose of all of
Nature and so the physicists in the same
here I mean has called us the Event
Horizon which is that disc that comes
out of every black hole to create a
Galaxy The Event Horizon is that magical
plane in which all of the light is being
compressed into particle State and
expressing itself as an asteroid belt or
planets or moons or Suns and so the way
in which a black hole forms matter is
this expression from waveform into
particle State and expresses Physical
Realm and then the Physical Realm gets
at some point Point go from physics to
biology and that's when things get
really bright the difference between a
sun and a single living cell is about
ten thousand times brighter at the
living cell level
cubic Center over by cubic centimeter a
cubic centimeter of the sun is 10 000
times dimmer than a cubic centimeter of
mitochondria that power you with light
energy
you burn 10 000 times Brighter Than The
Sun by the amount of light energy that
is released by life
so what is life it's a 10 000 time
concentration of the brightest things
physics ever created and so life is a
density of light expressed at the atomic
level yeah
and interestingly though just to finish
the thought yeah James Webb shows us 2.5
trillion galaxies and then you multiply
that by another 10 billion Suns or
something you're starting to get into
the same zone of the number of
mitochondria inside your body that
released the light energy of those Suns
and so we're at 14 quadrillion or so
mitochondria we could be off by a couple
zeros still and you're up in those
quadrillions of suns in the in the
universe and so in these weird ways we
start to realize that
nature is fractal what's true at the
micro level is true at the macro level
and these fractals of truths emanate
through it yeah yeah yeah I was gonna
well just kind of you know plan off of
that I've always thought like ever since
I understood how um you know an atom
works and uh you know the the I don't
know the whatever rotates the electrons
rotates around the center and I'm
looking at that um I was young when I
saw this and I'm like wait a minute I'm
like this looks like a little mini solar
system and if you so if you look at the
way atoms work and the way our solar
system works it's there's a there's a
center that things are spinning around
which is pretty pretty
um stinking fascinating but something
you said at lunch uh last week was about
how
light can carry information
and it I I didn't understand it when you
said it and but I was you know I hold
space for it and try to try to
understand it but it just so happens
like this is literally yet less uh
literally yesterday I was looking up
um because I go down these rabbit holes
on YouTube with uh math and physics and
stuff uh the double slit experiment and
last month uh what I should say in April
um they just did the the double slit
experiment with
um light or I'm sorry with yeah with
light and through that they did it with
time rather than like the actual slit
and I could go into what the double slit
experiment is but that's going to take
10 or 15 minutes to to explain but uh
the point being is is they they proved
that you can in fact uh use light to
carry information which is uh yeah it's
pretty pretty mind-blowing
so yeah and so you start to peer out
into the universe and you peer within
the human gut and you pure within the
human cell with all those mitochondria
teeming within your cells in 2000
mitochondria for every neuron that would
be there so 2 000 little Suns burning to
to ignite You Into Your Capacity to have
intelligence thought that's coming out
of the ecosystem that lives within you
and around you and then you start to
look at it 2.5 trillion other galaxies
with billions and billions of other Suns
with tens of billions of planets and you
start to really have to come to
terminals you know what we're probably
not alone yeah
and interestingly the news that we're
breaking right now and around the world
right now is only news to the West
really because if you go hang out with
any indigenous culture they say oh yeah
there's been extraterrestrial
intelligence all around us forever and
this is where the UFOs come and go and
we go here and you can see them coming
at night and they usually disappear into
the water or they go into that pyramid
and they I've been in Africa I've been
in South America I've been in South Asia
and they all say the same thing of like
oh yeah we're constantly in
communication with these things and so
the news that there's life outside of
the planet is not news to humans it's
just news to a western mind that decided
that the only safe place to be is at the
Pinnacle top of everything yeah yeah and
for that the colonial mind whether
Western or Eastern or whatever but that
Colonial mind that we need to control
everything for our own safety because we
fear death is what has driven us away
from the comfort with knowing that
there's extraterrestrial life all over
the place yeah
and so this is the News That's now
breaking uh big and and you know you
listeners can go deep into this now
there's long form interview with David
Crush
um that's uh released and David Rush is
one of the you know shining stars within
our special forces he was a physicist by
train he went into special ops and
worked deeply with the military across
different sectors I was deployed in
Afghanistan hero Among Us and uh did
deep work and then was assigned by the
Department of Defense a couple years ago
to
be kind of the head of their their UFO
task force and in their UFO UAE which is
the unidentified aerial activities and
things like this that people are terming
the UFO activity he went into it with an
incredible document that he wrote which
was I'm gonna go prove all this is yes I
am a physicist I know that all of these
you know stories of UFOs and abductions
and everything else aren't true blah
blah so he went in with eyes wide open
ready to prove it all wrong and over the
subsequent couple years you'll hear his
own story and David grush's long-form
interview that's coming out
um you know this week on multiple
different forms but David's stories are
about the fact that in the same way that
we fear death We Fear uh intelligence
outside of ourselves and so this fear
Paradigm has driven a cover-up that has
been so thorough but not perfect because
we've all heard the stories of UFOs
we've all seen the Declassified stuff
that came out of the Trump
Administration Declassified a whole
bunch of stuff trying to get this story
out a couple years ago but David garage
has you know had a head of Department of
Defense UFO project gave all this
testimony to the Senate arms community
and everything else in recent months and
so the stories are starting to break
across all all sectors now the fact that
there is a program called the program
that's been running for 90 years in the
U.S government and the program is uh
typically as as you'll see anytime we're
trying to hide information we fracture
the information soon you want doctors to
not really understand stand cancer or
disease in general you fracture them so
you say you're the specialist on that
protein you're the specialist on that
receptor you're the specialist here and
pretty soon nobody actually can see the
force from the trees and yet they all
are told they're the smartest most
intelligent most expert people on cancer
that was me 14 years ago expert in Coupe
tf1 a protein nobody's ever heard of but
I had a grant I was studying it I was
developing chemotherapy for Coupe tf1
receptor activation blah blah blah and
so the same thing has happened at the
governmental levels where information
was fractured out of fear we were afraid
of the big story yeah and we've been in
a cold war basically against other
governments since the 1940s with the
program and the program has been
designed to try to reverse engineer
extra human intelligence and their
Technologies for a Warfare advantage and
so we've been trying to get that
Paradigm shifting technology that we
could dominate the Russians or the
Chinese or whatever the stories have
been over the last 90 years it's out of
this fear of we need to kill them before
they can kill us and the first you know
really big recoveries of those crafts
that had enough technology to start to
reverse engineer happened in Italy in
1933 and Mussolini and his group there
took that content on and then the Third
Reich came in very quickly and
confiscated all that and so the Third
Reich was definitely working with these
technologies that helped a lot of things
Leap Forward during World War II jet
aircraft all kinds of things started
coming out of those German scientists
because they had stuff that we hadn't
seen before and they started to reverse
engineer this stuff at the same time you
know Accident Recovery sites were
achieved in the US and Roswell New
Mexico and other places and
um there's a whole you know task force
in the military that that David and
others are now describing that their job
is to go and as soon as there's a
suspicious wreck they go take it and put
it into hiding and then they they try to
figure out who could can reverse
engineer this stuff and unfortunately or
fortunately I don't know which but again
it gets further fraction where the
government loses track of that stuff
because they assign it to private sector
and so now it's you know Raytheon or
Boeing or all these big private
contractors for the military that are
given technology to say can you figure
this out can you reverse engineer this
and all that and so can you weaponize it
which is so fascinating Ryan and I grew
up in Dayton Ohio there's a great Air
Force Museum there and you see right
away like oh the right others are there
they're flying this little glider and
the the right flyer too and within 10
years what are we using it for how do we
kill people yeah how do we shoot people
in World War one and it sounds to me
like there's that parallel so I do want
to dive deep into this extraterrestrial
uh mindset but first I just wanted to
figure out why do you think that we tend
to weaponize everything that we create
eventually we find a way to batter other
people with a antibiotics probiotics yes
the anti-cancer yes chemotherapy
radiation yeah yeah the war on cancer
yeah I mean honestly it's it has it's
the same story over and over and over
again and it goes back to our first
podcast it is the fear of death that is
it yeah we literally are terrified of
death I'm going to kill what could kill
me
and I am separate and therefore
everything must be trying to kill me yes
this non-dual perspective it's this uh
is is uh we've lost it in a way right
everything has become this Duality the
other rising of everyone else and not
only am I separate from you I'm on a
pedestal apart from you I'm the only
non-idiot on the planet
um
yes we are trained so deeply into that
belief that I am smarter and more
deductive than anybody else around me
and therefore my story must be right
damn that's dangerous it's so Insidious
because it seems so safe
it's like okay I'm safe in my little
bubble and I can see the forward for the
trees nobody else can and I'm not going
to listen to other people that tell me
what that story is I'm not gonna trust
that and so it's a very Insidious
process that's led us to this belief
that my God we humans you know have to
be loved by God more than anybody else
and we are the purpose of God and all
that because we don't want to go to hell
you know as we created this whole other
domain of the concept of hell
to justify our fear of death
we had to create a story of Hell to
justify an inherent fear of death within
us hmm
but we're actually
just expressing symptoms
of a belief that what we see is what's
real and everything else must not be
real and so if you only come to trust
what you can physically see with your
eyes you are now trusting
0.0001 percent of the universe and
believing that that constitutes the
entire universe because for all those
2.5 trillion galaxies out there it's
still 0.0001 vacuum space right yeah our
0.0 physical versus the vacuum space
99.999 vacuum space that is full of all
the light information
and so this is where we get into dark
matter and all these fudge factors that
we use mathematically because we weren't
calculating the density of Light Within
the electromagnetic field within that
vacuum space and turns out it's 13-0 is
more dense than all of the physical
matter in the universe Preston in a
cubic centimeter one cubic centimeter of
emptiness is 13 zeros denser than all
physical structure of these entire
universe all 2.5 trillion galaxies
pushed into that same cubic centimeter
it's 13 zeros longer for an empty space
State and so we have so miscalculated
the universe and so this whole 94 of the
universe must be dark matter and all
this stuff no it's just light energy
being expressed in the form of
electromagnetic field within the vacuum
that's the density of the universe and
that density then dictates the behavior
of that 0.001 and so we have come to
believe a universe through this little
pixel of reality and then we tell
ourselves all kinds of stories to
justify the experience of believing
that's all that there is and so as we
start to come to terms with the fact
that there are intelligent systems
within the universe that way out out map
our capacity and have been here for
millions of years longer than we have
likely
we have to start to back up and just say
what is real honestly what is real and
the answer is light there's only one
thing that's real and that's expression
of waveform or frequency of vibration in
the universe and from that comes
everything else
and so are we gonna pretend like
everything is outside of ourselves as
Darkness or are we going to come
determined with it is all light energy
and the form of the electromagnetic
field that is expressing life itself
expressing physical matter it expresses
the Sun the moon the stars the asteroids
everything else and ultimately humanity
and so we have to come to terms of the
fact that we bought into a fear Paradigm
that kept us locked in this tiny little
box of beliefs tiny little box and we
were trained to fear everything outside
of that box and so as we come to terms
with the fact that all this information
now coming out and government officials
not only saying that we've recovered
a spacecraft we've also recovered the
alien the alien intelligence and I
really like what they're doing and what
David grush's you know explanation and
he's so physics oriented I love love the
way he speaks but he points out that
calling them aliens is ridiculous
because we don't actually have enough
data to know where they come from his
point is they've probably been here long
before humans because they've been
around with these Technologies likely
millions of years versus our mere 300
000 years as humans they've been around
longer on Earth likely than us and so
what they're doing here who knows is
this something they call home or is this
an outpost is this a biologic
experiments they're running here on the
planet to create life who knows
but the fact is to call them alien is
probably ridiculous because it suggests
that they're over there and we're over
here and there from that star and we're
from this start and that's just not how
life exists right we are all an
expression of one thing on the end and
we are all home
all the time and I want to just
emphasize that because I'm somebody who
has walked around for decades feeling
not at home
I had a box of belief about who I was
and therefore I felt like an alien in my
own planet and I felt like I was not
part of this human system because I
didn't understand it didn't feel like
home it didn't feel comfortable and in
the end I find out we are all home
all of the time everywhere in the
universe because we are the vibration of
One Source we are the vibration of this
universe and this universe is expressing
all of life here all of it whether it be
from distant star systems or Earth it's
all there and so first of all there is
no such thing as alien
there's only a home and life is home in
this universe and so that's a reframing
that I think we desperately need as we
start to come to terms with all this
news pouring out now from governments
and everything else as we come to terms
with the fact that not only were there
species recovered in these racks there
were living species recovered in these
wrecks and so these governments are now
coming forward or at least government
officials coming forward to acknowledge
that there have been treaties signed
with these other
uh species and the U.S seems to by
David's report and others seems to be
pointing to the Eisenhower
Administration to be the first president
to sign A Treatise with a a non-human
race or human species an
extraterrestrial wow I mean a
terrestrial at this point right they're
here where they come from could be
debated right but a non-human
intelligence yeah give it that if I were
to follow this down a path because I'm
still hyper skeptical about this but if
I fall down a path what you're saying is
it's potential that it's not
extraterrestrial at all it's just
a species that started here and maybe
went somewhere else and came back that's
a that's one of many possibilities yeah
and and David lays that out that it's
possible things are coming from distant
parts of the these you know 2.5 trillion
galaxies but it's also possible we're
looking at
a future version of us that's simply
developed non-linear reality because you
you mentioned the slit experiment what
they prove is a slit experiment is time
is totally relative right that's
relativity with Einstein and everybody
else and he actually time is totally
bendable and you can bend space-time you
can connect this Dot and time to this
distant dot in time you can bring them
right together and it can be the same
thing so as our species continues to
progress isn't it likely that over the
next million years we get non-linear
relationship through relativity and
improved Technologies for quantum
physics interaction all that
or either that we get to the point where
we let go of all so much biologic trauma
in our genetics and I let go of my
ancestry completely and I become so
present that I am the the highest
technology in the land and my body can
now do space-time bending because I am
no longer tied to a root system of
epigenetic trauma and so I believe we
really are the highest
technology on the planet I believe that
nothing here no spacecraft anything else
competes with the Brilliance of what
lies within me
and that technology I believe can do all
kinds of things that we can't yet
imagine in the human mind and so is it
really extraterrestrial intelligence
we're dealing with or is it a future us
that's coming back to try to move us
forward oh wow are they actually working
with us not against us is possible and
so these are the these are the framings
that I would invite all of you in the
audience to start to just sit with
because I don't have your truths I don't
have your answers to this and you're
going to have to take in this
information from not just David rush but
Professor Nolan a couple articles have
already come out from Professor Nolan at
Stanford and Nolan was approached by the
CIA he's a pathologist microbiologist
um they approached him with 100 cases of
of humans that were presenting with very
strange diseases and didn't tell them
anything more than that can you figure
out what's going on in the neurology and
the brains of these humans and as a
pathologist microbiologists who started
to dissect kind of what was the the
common injury at the neurology level of
these people in Dr Nolan was then
introduced to the reality that all the
people had one thing in common is that
they were exposed to extraterrestrial
intelligence or or some sort of
Technologies coming from these non-human
sources and so these soldiers and other
people being exposed to these
Technologies had these deep injuries to
their their their life form and so they
were trying to tease that out so that
was Nolan's introduction to you know
this whole concept and he's been able to
you know be with and and spend time with
one of those orb technologies that
you've seen on you know a lot of the
military Air Force images that are done
of UFOs you see these very fast
traveling 20 000 mile an hour orbs that
travel they're just spheres that seem to
have no propulsion anything else and so
he's been able to study that one of
those Technologies and try to figure out
what is there what is the radiation
Source or whatever it is and the answer
is it's these isotopes of metals that
that don't really exist on the planet
and so there seems to be some sort of
true extraterrestrial
energies or extraterrestrial materials
Within These Technologies whatever's
being used or it's an ability of humans
to start to do transmutation of the
elements where we can start to build
elements from the periodic table with
with further Discovery so
so he's uncovering that biologic side
well well David is is you know
uncovering you know through the through
the Department of Defense again he's
Department of Defense contractor's wife
CAA like it's not like this is been foil
wearing people in New Mexico this is
really the heart of our government and
and special forces and and Central
Intelligence agencies coming forward
with this information
and again I want to take us back to
forgiveness because I believe that one
of our greatest dangers at this moment
is this information comes out is that we
further divide ourselves and we fear
again
and I started talking about this in
podcasts during the pandemic when they
started to release all the UFO data I
was like ah this is perfect preparation
for the next biggest fear of Paradigm
story so here we were in the biggest
fear story that had ever been told
here's a virus that's going to kill the
planet everybody needs to go in your
home we're going to put tanks in the
street we're gonna lock you all down for
your own safety
and then as that started to remit and go
away oh my gosh
government's got alien information all
these UFOs
the aliens are going to attack us we
need to print as the U.S 40 trillion
dollars and we need to put tanks in the
street you need to go back in your home
to hide away from the attack and so I'm
nervous that we're going to turn this
into a fear of Paradigm instead of an
opportunity to connect to a universal
intelligence yeah I want to get all the
facts on the table here in a moment
and I also want to spend some time
interrogating those facts together yeah
I'm looking forward to TK's yeah he came
here with half his brain tied behind his
back so I'm gonna need him to untie that
well yeah hold on he was he was
hospitalized recently and and so he's
and I'm a little drugged up and all that
stuff he's back right now this is the
second episode since that
hospitalization but I do want to
interrogate those facts I want to get
them on the table and I think the three
of us we need to find ways to push back
in a way that helps give us a deeper
understanding of exactly what the
implications are of that so I think
we'll spend another 30 or 45 minutes
talking about that but first let me play
a few minimalist insights from some of
our listeners
why this message for the breakup episode
hi this is Tess in Seattle and I
recently had a breakup with a boyfriend
and I know this is more of a comment
than a question I have just found that
being in situations that are not the
right situations to be in be it family
friends or boyfriend sometimes have us
do things that are not so good and
sometimes that means buying things or
being more I guess of a consumer than an
experiencer of things and I have found
that since my breakup things just really
don't matter and that life is actually
pretty awesome and experiences mean more
and more and I just think that sometimes
we don't realize that we're in the
middle of something that isn't the right
place so keep an eye I guess and my
ideas keeping an eye on when are you
doing things that aren't healthy and
when are you doing other things in your
private team that aren't optimal and
then stop and think what's around you
and what makes you do that thank you all
right wow
um we just had a conversation yeah and
we you got a little bit of it on this
minimal episode you can head on over to
patreon.com the minimalist seven day
trial for free go ahead and listen to
the full conversation that's really all
I can say because we dive deep in ways
that I think we disagreed with Dr Bush
we didn't completely understand doctor
but he's talking about aliens
extraterrestrial UFOs it's yeah it's
crazy man I never thought that we would
ever talk about anything like this on
the podcast and the fact that we were
able to hold such a
um I don't know such a a a patient
conversation around this topic um it was
really really fascinating man I was most
fascinated at TK that we sort of all
ended up on the same page even if we
don't have the same beliefs about this
we were able to form a day taunt with
our understanding and our
misunderstanding absolutely man like it
was a good illustration of the fact that
conversations about our differences are
about something deeper than our
differences right it's about the energy
that makes connection possible and what
I love so much about the way Dr Zach
bush had that conversation is he was
calm and composed unabashed Unapologetic
the entire time he felt no need to force
anything down our throats and at the
same time he didn't get defensive or
riled up when we asked some questions
and and expressed some skepticism about
certain possibilities it was cool that's
how conversation should be yes yeah and
I felt the whole time that there was no
it wasn't a judgmental approach even
though I'm like I wanted to be like what
the oh my God and throughout the whole
thing I would TK's really helped me with
this he's helped me be more curious
about other World Views and Dr Zach bush
is someone I really respect I obviously
really respect Ryan when Ryan came to me
with this conversation that he wanted to
have on the podcast I said yes not
because I agreed with it and I still
can't say that I'm completely on board
with any of it but what we did here
especially through that long form
conversation is we opened up a door for
more understanding yeah I don't want to
say that you know any of us actually
believe or disbelieve in it but able to
hold space and have that conversation
and listen
um that's what I really appreciate about
what just went down yes indeed well
that's our minimal episode for today
we'll see on patreon for the full three
hour maximal edition of this episode
which includes answers to a bunch more
questions about the gut as well not just
aliens but questions like what can I do
about seasonal allergies as I get older
What factors contribute to eating
disorders plus a million more questions
for Dr Zach Bush and much much more of
less and if you want to hear all that
check out the minimalist private podcast
patreon.com the minimalist or click the
link in the description big thanks to
Our Guest today Dr Zach Bush head on
over to the minimalists.com you can see
all of the the show notes will link to
not only Zach Bush's website but his
non-profits and all the things he talked
about throughout the episode today if
you all live here today with just one
message please let it be this
love people
and use things
because the opposite never works
thanks for listening y'all we'll see you
next time peace
every little thing you think that you
need
need every little thing that's just
feeding your greed oh I bet that you'll
be fine without it thank you foreign
every little